the increasing access to coveted booster
shots for tens of millions of americans
more than 70 million people are now
eligible to get an additional shot after
government health officials gave the
okay to boosters for the modern and
johnson and johnson vaccinations this
week and late last night the food and
drug administration reported strong
evidence that pfizer's reduced-dose
vaccine shot could help children between
the ages of 5 and 11. elise preston is
here with the very latest elise good
morning good morning dana here's the
breakdown on booster eligibility for
adults anyone who has taken the johnson
and johnson single dose vaccine is
eligible to get a booster with a pfizer
or moderna vaccines highly recommended
for those already vaccinated with either
the pfizer or moderna vaccines people 65
or older they are eligible for another
shot and anyone 18 or older with a
pre-existing condition or who lives in a
long-term care facility
yesterday morning in richmond virginia
robert gray was more than ready for his
moderna booster i woke up to the news
this morning and
it was approved and got right online
made my appointment came right down and
while the pandemic is still taking toll
with 75 000 new cases and 1500 deaths
each day colorado's governor rolling up
his sleeve yesterday emphasized many are
at greater risk
teachers
first responders work in a retail store
work in an office environment where
cubicles near other people and you're
going in
you want you want the safety that this
third dose can provide individuals can
now decide to mix vaccines to increase
protection a small national institute of
health study awaiting peer review found
three doses of moderna offered the
highest level of protection followed by
two shots of pfizer then moderna anyone
who received the johnson and johnson
single dose vaccine would be more
protected if they got either the pfizer
or modernist shot as a booster to better
protect adults who took the johnson and
johnson shot health officials have
minimized the requirements for them for
those who got j and j
everybody is eligible if you got your
dose more than two months ago so anybody
who got j and j if their doses more than
two months ago then they are eligible
for a boost federal regulators indicated
late last night the benefits to the
nation's 25 million children from five
to 11 years receiving a reduced dose of
the pfizer vaccine are far greater than
the risks and the white house says it's
getting ready what we're really focusing
on is working with pediatricians we know
that the pediatricians are
one of the most trusted sources of
information for any parent
an fda advisory committee meeting
scheduled for this coming week will
consider pfizer's modified vaccine for
children if approved by the fda children
could begin receiving the shots in early
november pfizer's own data shows the
vaccine is 91 percent effective at
preventing coveted infections in
children late last night an independent
fda advisory panel gave pfizer's vaccine
for children a favorable review michelle
all right elise thank you